[Aplausos]
[Música]
m
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la guerra de ucrania nos ha hecho
acostumbrarnos a escuchar noticias sobre
las sanciones y los bloqueos de activos
financieros yates aviones propiedades
inmobiliarias y un sinfín de riquezas de
toda índole en manos de los oligarcas
rusos ahora bien que conocemos
exactamente como un oligarca son ellos
los auténticos dueños de rusia los
mandamases en la sombra hasta donde
llega a su poder quiénes son
este seguro de que muchos al escuchar el
término oligarcas rusos penséis en
millonarios con mucho poder y si
simplificando las cosas podríamos decir
que son algo así sin embargo esa misma
definición podría aplicarse por ejemplo
a muchos multimillonarios
norteamericanos sin ir más lejos ahí
está el caso de donald trump un
multimillonario que llegó a ocupar el
puesto de poder más importante de los
estados unidos de américa y quizás de
todo el mundo pero evidentemente trump
no es un oligarca y sería un error
etiquetarlo de esa forma queridos amigos
amigas en este vídeo os vamos a contar
cómo funciona el sistema político ruso
en la sombra quiénes son los auténticos
dueños de rusia y cómo son las
relaciones entre el kremlin y los
oligarcas atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
desde que vladimir putin desató su
tormenta de fuego destrucción y
aniquilación sobre ucrania hemos hablado
mucho de oligarcas pero que es
exactamente un oligarca creo amigos que
hasta la primera pregunta que tenemos
que responder pues bien los oligarcas
rusos son empresarios extremadamente
ricos cuyas fortunas y negocios dependen
esencialmente de cuál próximo sean al
kremlin
[Música]
los oligarcas rusos se han convertido en
algo así como la guardia pretoriana del
poder político la extensión los brazos
políticos del kremlin en el terreno
económico porque la economía rusa es
algo así como una economía cerrada y
centralizada donde los funcionarios y
los burócratas han sido sustituidos por
empresarios rentistas que se abren paso
a golpe de influencia coacción o
sobornos en la rusia actual no opera un
modelo capitalista ni tampoco uno de
corte socialista la rusia de putin es
algo así como la misma representación de
un mercantilismo de camarilla moderno un
modelo donde las grandes empresas
reciben todo tipo de privilegios del
poder político a cambio de respaldarlo y
seguir sus directrices por lo tanto en
este país la relación entre riqueza
privada y poder público es muy pero que
muy estrecha los oligarcas dirigen y
controlan sectores estratégicos para los
intereses de moscú como por ejemplo la
energía o la defensa
[Aplausos]
ahora bien cómo se materializa todo esto
en la práctica es esto algo nuevo de la
rusia de vladimir putin pues lo cierto
es que no
de hecho podríamos decir que como mínimo
ya vamos por la segunda generación de
oligarcas rusos porque amigos la primera
generación surgió del caótico proceso de
privatizaciones que el país experimentó
durante los años 90 cuando el estado
ruso vendió a coste de saldo muchas de
las grandes empresas públicas de la era
soviética fue un proceso atestado de
corrupción que tuvo como referencia los
esquemas de préstamos por acción es un
sistema que utilizó las acciones de
grandes empresas públicas de recursos
naturales como una especie de aval de
préstamos para el gobierno federal y
como el gobierno federal no devolvió
esos préstamos de forma sospechosamente
intencionada entonces los acreedores que
eran magnates y personajes cercanos al
poder subastaron esas acciones para
recuperar sus préstamos por supuesto
opacas y amañadas donde ellos mismos se
presentaban como los únicos compradores
y así es como nacieron los oligarcas y
como éstos tomaron el control de las
grandes empresas del país de esta forma
los funcionarios y burócratas públicos
fueron sustituidos por estos nuevos
empresarios del socialismo se pasó al
mercantilismo de camarilla todo este
proceso se produjo durante la era de
helsinn pero en realidad la época de
putin no ha sido muy diferente si acaso
una evolución de este sistema
[Música]
boris yeltsin y vladimir putin eran
personajes antagónicos que además si a
pesar de sus lazos políticos se llevaban
fatal y por supuesto cada uno contaba
con sus propios grupos de influencia que
en la práctica también eran adversarios
así que computen llegó la segunda
generación de oligarcas su entorno fue
abriéndose paso a través de generosos
contratos concesiones y permisos del
gobierno para explotar las riquezas del
país o supuestamente desarrollar la
industria nacional de esta forma poco a
poco fueron ocupando los peldaños más
altos de la estructura económica rusa
si puede que os sorprenda pero el
mercantilismo de camarilla de rusia no
funciona de forma muy diferente a los
grupos mafiosos de hecho el presidente
ruso es todo un especialista en quitarse
de medio a cualquier persona que le
incomode por ejemplo dirigiendo campañas
contra la población
ahí está por ejemplo el caso de mijaíl
jodorkovski un oligarca muy próximo a
yeltsin y una de las mayores fortunas de
rusia que fue encarcelado en 2003 bajo
acusaciones de corrupción jodorkovski
era el propietario de la petrolera rusa
yukos empresa que le fue expropiada por
el gobierno
26 de octubre del 2003 la policía en
rusia captura a magnate petrolero el
hombre más rico de rusia el barón del
petróleo mijail jodorkovski fue
capturado a punta de pistola el sábado
por agentes de seguridad del gobierno y
encarcelado bajo cargos de fraude y
evasión de impuestos si puede que todas
estas acusaciones fueran ciertas pero
desde luego no eran algo excepcional la
corrupción forma parte necesaria del
modelo político imperante en el país
esta operación en el año 2003 contra la
mayor fortuna de rusia fue el primer
disparo de advertencia de putin a los
oligarcas algo así como
y mucho ojo si queréis ir por libre
sufriréis las consecuencias estáis ahí
gracias al poder político así que si no
sois completamente leales lo pagaréis
muy caro
[Música]
es decir aquí no hablamos de empresarios
que compiten entre sí y asumen riesgos
no para nada el modelo mercantilista
ruso sustituye la competencia por los
tratos de favor el tráfico de
influencias los sobornos y las
corruptelas de todo tipo los oligarcas a
cambio de sus fortunas adquieren el
compromiso de mantener la estabilidad la
lealtad al poder político e intentar
llevar sus empresas lo mejor posible al
menos mejor que los resultados que
cosechaban cuando eran públicas pero
ahora que sabemos que es exactamente un
oligarca y por qué se habla tanto de
ellos la pregunta es quiénes son
exactamente los dueños de rusia qué
cambios trajo consigo vladimir putin
hasta donde alcanza la influencia del
presidente ruso sobre las grandes
empresas del país pues bien veámoslo
sí
los accionistas de rusia
el modelo oligárquico ruso tal y como ya
os hemos contado ha pasado
fundamentalmente por dos etapas la de
helsinn y la de putin la primera se
caracterizó por el enorme poder político
que cosecharon algunos oligarcas en
algunas ocasiones incluso le dictaban al
gobierno el rumbo de sus políticas o
llegaron a convertirse en miembros del
gabinete o en el gobierno sin embargo en
la segunda etapa esta situación cambió
radicalmente putin estableció a golpe de
puño unas relaciones muy diferentes los
oligarcas ya no interferirían ni
condicionarían al gobierno el poder de
rusia está en el kremlin no en las sedes
de estas compañías
[Música]
de esta forma putin impulsó normas y
leyes para que los grandes oligarcas de
las industrias estratégicas como la
energía la minería o los medios de
comunicación le vendieran parte de sus
acciones al estado o entidades
controladas por este ley de asier a
estrechar mucho más los lazos entre el
kremlin y las grandes corporaciones
rusas y así es como nacieron las
llamadas corporaciones estatales a las
que putin blindó legalmente contratos
preferentes y privilegios de todo tipo
se estima que estas corporaciones
controlan hoy el 55 por ciento de la
economía rusa y es toda una variante del
capitalismo de estado que le ha dado al
presidente ruso un control sin
precedentes sobre los sectores
productivos más importantes del país y
también sobre sus dueños
[Música]
es decir en la práctica a diferencia de
la hiel sin los oligarcas rusos ya no se
limitan a ser los propietarios de
grandes conglomerados industriales sino
sobre todo son los responsables de
gestionar estos grupos en nombre del
kremlin de esta forma los sobornos y las
rentas que se extraen de estas grandes
empresas alcanzan a todos los resortes
del poder del país
ese es el gran cambio que se ha
producido y lo que ha dado a vladimir
putin un poder sin precedentes y esto es
también lo que explica que a pesar de
todas las sanciones internacionales que
rusia está sufriendo tras la invasión de
ucrania los oligarcas apenas se hayan
pronunciado porque ahora ellos dependen
de putin más de lo que putin depende de
ellos por supuesto este sistema conlleva
unos niveles de productividad innovación
y competitividad muy pobres pero
garantiza una estabilidad enorme para
todas las partes bueno casi todas las
partes porque la inmensa mayoría de los
rusos ni pincha ni corta pero ha dicho
esto hay una pregunta en el aire quiénes
son exactamente los principales
oligarcas del país
[Música]
los amigos del kremlin
actualmente en rusia podemos encontrar
tres tipos de oligarcas primero están
los amigos de putin que son los que
están conectados en el terreno personal
con el presidente su círculo más próximo
hablamos por ejemplo de antiguos amigos
de san petersburgo de donde procede el
presidente ruso o ex compañeros en la
calle luego están los líderes de los
servicios de seguridad la fsb la policía
y el ejército que son conocidos como
siloviki y por último tenemos a los
outsiders pues bien respecto a los
primeros los íntimos de putin se trata
de un grupo de personas que literalmente
le deben todo a putin personas que han
logrado multiplicar su riqueza hasta
niveles inimaginables desde que putin
llegó al poder son los fieles entre los
fieles
[Música]
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de yuri
kovalchuk conocido como el banquero
personal de putin y que amasa una
fortuna de unos 1700 millones de dólares
actualmente es el principal accionista
de rossi ya bank uno de los bancos más
importantes del país pero si éstos
parece mucho dinero atentos al caso de
leonid mijelson otro amigo personal del
presidente ruso mijelson cuenta con una
fortuna que se estima en 18 mil 100
millones de dólares y ocupa actualmente
el número 66 entre las personas más
ricas del mundo según forbes mijelson es
fundador y director de novatech una
empresa de gas natural que actualmente
está sancionada por occidente
precisamente por sus vínculos con el
kremlin
luego otro amigo personal del presidente
gennari timchenko ha logrado amasar una
fortuna de 15 mil 700 millones de
dólares a través del grupo volga su
empresa de inversión mediante la que
invierte en corporaciones controladas
por otros oligarcas
[Música]
y luego por el lado de los siloviki de
los oligarcas que proceden de los
servicios de seguridad y demás tenemos
el ejemplo de igor sechín que ahora es
presidente de la petrolera rusa rosneft
pero que en los 80 era un espía
soviético en mozambique aunque
oficialmente su actividad era la de ser
un mero traductor putin entendió muy
pronto que tener el control pleno de los
servicios de seguridad y hacerse con la
lealtad absoluta de sus líderes
resultaba un paso clave para consolidar
su poder así que los enriqueció de forma
desmesurada y luego finalmente por el
lado de los outsiders tenemos a una
serie de hombres que lograron salvarse
de la purga de oligarcas que putin hizo
tras la era y el zinc
uno de ellos es vladimir potanin que se
benefició del esquema de préstamos por
acciones de yeltsin hasta logran amasar
hoy una fortuna de 16 mil 500 millones
de dólares potanin es propietario del 30
por ciento de norilsk nickel una
importante empresa minera así como de
participaciones en empresas de seguros
medios de comunicación petróleo y un
largo etcétera
ya lo veis en rúsia las fortunas no se
construyen por ingenio empresarial sino
sobre todo por influencias con el
kremlin y ojo porque no hablamos de
fortunas precisamente menores los
grandes millonarios rusos acumulan un
patrimonio que se valora entre los 400 y
los 800 mil millones de dólares el
problema es que este modelo permite
hacer funcionar empresas básicas pero no
desarrollar negocios demasiado complejos
y ese es exactamente uno de los mayores
problemas de rusia
el país ha sido incapaz de ser algo más
que un mero exportador de recursos
naturales y luego la corrupción ahoga
cualquier posible evolución esto es lo
que explica que rusia sea uno de los
países más desiguales y menos prósperos
del mundo por supuesto el incentivo de
los grandes oligarcas rusos pasa por ser
incondicionales al kremlin vivir la vida
y convertirse en embajadores de moscú en
las plazas más ricas del mundo claro que
ahora las sanciones se están golpeando
duro
[Música]
como veis golpear a los grandes
oligarcas equivale a golpear al estado
ruso por eso los aliados les han puesto
en la diana también esperan que una
presión suficiente pueda llegar incluso
a provocar un movimiento de sillas en
moscú al fin y al cabo se confía en que
nadie quiere perder su estatus todo esto
explica por qué muchos países están
sancionando los oligarcas incluso con
más ímpetu que a otras instituciones
rusas fijaos
[Música]
de momento tal y como ya os hemos
contado en un pasado boletín de patrón
los oligarcas rusos están buscando
refugio en lugares como dubai a la hora
de la verdad ellos son quizás los que
menos se fían de putin por cierto si
queréis recibir nuestro boletín las
claves de la semana no tenéis más que
sumarnos a nuestra comunidad de patrián
con vuestra ayuda podremos hacer crecer
aún más este proyecto y crear más y
mejor contenido independiente y por el
camino además de las claves de la semana
podría recibir también la tan polític
contenido exclusivo y merchandising
único os dejamos el link abajo en la
descripción pero dicho esto turno para
ti crees que las sanciones conducirán a
los oligarcas a traicionar a putin qué
os parece esta especie de mercantilismo
de camarilla que gobierna rusia deben
los gobiernos occidentales perseguir sin
tregua a los oligarcas rusos lejanos
porque bajo tus impresiones y ahora así
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like i
suscribiros a visual político un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]